[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour ici l'Europe ça y est
c'est véritablement la rentrée
européenne puisqu'à eu lieu mercredi
dernier le discours sur l'état de
l'Union devant l'hémicycle de Strasbourg
prononcé par la présidente de la
Commission européenne
Ursula Vendée nous y consacrerons une
bonne partie de cette émission
l'atmosphère était d'ailleurs électrique
et politique à 9 mois des élections
européennes avec des clivages très
apparents sur des sujets diverses comme
la géopolitique ou encore la transition
énergétique voilà pourquoi nous avons
invité aujourd'hui celle qui a été
désignée tête de liste d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts pour la France pour les
prochaines élections évidemment le
prochain scrutin ce qui veut dire
d'ailleurs qu'une liste commune de la
gauche n'est pas forcément d'actualité
on va on va en reparler Marie tout ça
bonjour à 36 ans juriste vous êtes
illustré dans le combat de l'affaire du
siècle
on sent l'inaction climatique de de
l'État français votre choix a plutôt été
une surprise d'ailleurs pour les Verts
et le grand public j'ai envie de
demander pourquoi vous pourquoi moi je
crois que je suis une militante engagée
qui mène effectivement ses combats
contre l'inaction climatiques mais aussi
pour la préservation du vivant pour la
justice dans le sens aussi compris de la
justice sociale qui mène des combats
avec la société et dans l'hémicycle de
façon déterminée voilà donc moi je suis
peut-être moins surprise que vous
votre état de l'Union à vous j'ai envie
de vous demander justement comment se
porte notre union à 27 selon votre
grille d'analyse alors l'Union est dans
un état critique d'abord quand on
regarde comment va la population
européenne et comment va l'Europe aussi
dans ses écosystèmes on voit bien que la
situation est extrêmement difficile
l'Europe tout entière comme d'ailleurs
le monde et je pense notamment à la
Libye a été ravagée par les feux de
forêt on a des si ça pauvrissent des
nappes phréatiques qui se vident des
sécheresses du manque d'eau partout sur
le territoire européen on a aussi un
taux de pauvreté qui augmente un
Européen sur 3 selon les restos du cœur
ne parvient plus à manger à sa fin à
chaque repas on compte plus de 200000
enfants en risque de pauvreté si ils ne
le sont pas déjà et donc on voit bien
que la situation à la fois écologique et
sociale et d'ailleurs à mon sens c'est
la même est extrêmement difficile quant
à l'Union européenne en termes
d'institutions de politique et bien elle
est effectivement dans un moment
charnière un moment critique est-ce que
nous allons faire le choix et notamment
c'est la question qui sera posée en juin
prochain est-ce que nous allons faire le
choix d'un renforcement des nationaux
populisme on a un renforcement
d'un projet politique et suit d'une
Europe blanche chrétienne inamovible et
d'une Europe de la haine où est-ce que
on va au contraire faire le choix d'une
Europe qui continue le pacte vert qui
continue et qui renforce qui accélère la
transformation écologique et sociale de
notre société c'est le moment dans
lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui et le
discours dont soulève wanderleon n'a pas
permis de trancher la direction qui sera
la sienne parce que vous parlez du pacte
vert mais on l'a constaté d'ailleurs au
moment quelques il y a quelques mois
d'un vote sur la loi sur la biodiversité
la droite du parti populaire européen le
plus gros parti ici au Parlement
européen
semble vouloir tout faire pour freiner
un certain nombre de textes à venir vous
pensez que certains textes vont rester
lettre morte oui c'est très clair la
droite européenne le Parti populaire
européen a appelé en mai dernier à une
pause un moratoire sur le pacte vert on
a adopté aujourd'hui
c'est aussi au niveau de Emmanuel Macron
donc ça a débordé les rangs de la droite
traditionnelle mais ce moratoire cette
demande de moratoire elle intervient au
moment où on a adopté 40% seulement des
législations relatives au pacte vert qui
était le programme de la majorité
politique aujourd'hui en
que c'est possible finalement que à
l'issue des élections du 6 au 9 juin il
y a une majorité complètement à droite
de ce Parlement européen entre la droite
traditionnelle et la droite beaucoup
plus radicale où c'est un scénario
fantasy moi je ne sais jamais à la
fatalité mais par contre oui je suis
inquiète la réalité c'est qu'on a
aujourd'hui des tractations des
discussions des débats des pactes pour
l'instant thématique et des accords
gouvernementaux dans un certain nombre
d'État membres et donc ce qui était
inimaginable il y a encore cinq ans
devient totalement possible pour la
prochaine mandature donc c'est l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles il faut
absolument que les Européennes et les
Européens se mobilisent pour aller voter
le 9 juin prochain c'est parce qu'il y a
cette menace effectivement de cette
majorité là qui apparaît possible aussi
selon les sondages aujourd'hui mais
quand je dis que je fais cette pas à la
fatalité c'est que je crois tout à fait
possible que ce choix d'une autre Europe
dont je parlais tout à l'heure qui est
celui de la transformation écologique et
sociale qui s'occupe véritablement qui
prennent soin une robe du Caire qui
prennent soin tant des êtres humains
dans les hôpitaux dans la vie
quotidienne pour les femmes pour les
enfants pour les personnes vulnérables
que des écosystèmes cette Europe du soin
elle existe elle est possible et je
crois qu'elle est désirable alors est-ce
que justement au nom de l'économie qui a
beaucoup invoqué la présidente de la
Commission européenne des petites
entreprises des agriculteurs ils
risquent d'y avoir des manœuvres
houleuses autour des prochains textes du
pacte vert on pense au CE2 des camions
et des bus à limiter les nouvelles
techniques génomiques à préserver la
qualité de l'air et tout autre texte par
exemple sur les pesticides est-ce que ça
ça pourrait justement faire l'objet d'un
blocage oui et vous savez ce qui
m'inquiète le plus ce sont deux choses
c'est la nature et les produits
chimiques et toxiques ça vous parle
beaucoup de climats dans la réalité il y
a neuf limite planétaires c'est à dire 9
limites dont le CO2 mais aussi la
biodiversité l'eau les pollutions
chimiques et toxiques qui définissent
l'espace dans lequel la vie humaine est
en sécurité sur terre et bien sur ces 9
limites nous en dépassons 6 et pas un le
CO2 or ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui dans
cette bataille de la droite européenne
c'est une bataille contre le vivant donc
ils se sont opposés à la loi sur la
restauration de la nature le texte qui
reste en négociation est quasiment vidé
de sa substance alors que 80% des
écosystèmes européens sont dégradés et
que ce sont ces écosystèmes qui
absorbent aussi le CO2 s'il ne souhaite
pas avancer sur la réduction de
l'utilisation des pesticides qui est
aussi absolument indispensable pour la
santé humaine ou vous situer d'ailleurs
le commissaire en charge à savoir le
français Thierry Breton en charge du
marché intérieur que certains accusent
d'avoir été actifs au sein de la
commission aux côtés des lobbies de la
chimie pour empêcher une réforme sur les
pesticides ça c'est l'autre limite
planétaire dont je vous parlais c'est à
dire les produits chimiques et toxiques
vous savez on a eu cette immense enquête
européenne avec ce grand scandale
sanitaire sur les polluants éternels que
sont les pfas qui sont des polluants qui
s'inscrivent partout dans les sols dans
l'eau dans les corps qu'on retrouve dans
les corps des personnes particuliers des
ouvriers ou des riverains des zones
indus et qui nous rendent malades et qui
se transmettent de génération en
génération les produits toxiques c'est
aussi le plomb une grande enquête qui
est sorti pour montrer que 5 millions de
personnes meurent chaque année
et bien le rôle de Thierry Breton et que
on a absolument besoin de réviser les
règles qui sont aujourd'hui en vigueur
dans l'Union européenne justement parce
que ça rend les gens et les écosystèmes
malades on doit le réviser d'urgence il
y a un besoin de prendre soin je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure mais Thierry Breton
s'oppose effectivement avec le lobby de
la chimie en particulier un lobby qui
s'appelle sefik mais aussi d'autres
comme Arkema par exemple qui est Open à
côté de Lyon et bien il s'oppose à ce
que c'est législations soient révisées
pourquoi bien tout simplement pour
préserver leur profit et donc quel que
soit l'endroit où on regarde il y a une
lutte acharnée de d'un certain nombre
d'industries contre de meilleur
législations environnement et la
patronne de la Commission européenne qui
elle aussi du Parti populaire européen
effectivement on veut beaucoup au loup
et elle veut une révision du statut de
protection pour cet animal vous
comprenez pourquoi je comprends pourquoi
et je vais vous dire pourquoi c'est
plutôt en 2019 quand on soulève un lion
a été élu il y avait une forte
mobilisation en faveur du climat et donc
elle fait de la réelle politique et elle
s'est dit je vais faire du climat le
cœur de maman nature sauf que trois ans
après quatre ans après comme on l'a dit
la droite européenne se mobilise les
industries européennes les plus riches
parce que je veux pas pointer du doigt
toute l'industrie un certain nombre
d'industrie se mobilisent contre la
nature contre le vivant l'agrobusiness
que je différencie des paysans ou encore
les exploitants forestiers industriels
que je différencie des petits forestiers
ou des pêcheurs artisanaux par exemple
vis-à-vis de la pêche industrielle on a
ces gros lobbys qui se mobilisent et qui
pousse sous l'avant-dernière à mettre
elle-même un terme à son propre
programme politique la question du loup
elle intègre en totalement ce paysage
politique là c'est à dire qu'en novembre
dernier il y a moins d'un an la
Commission européenne la Commission
européenne disait les populations de
nous sont encore trop fragiles il faut
prendre ces sujets avec prudence et 9
mois plus tard elle revient et elle nous
dit il y a trop de loups regardons où
est-ce qu'il pas trop pour pouvoir
octroyer de nouveaux nouvelles
dérogations de tir alors que les règles
en vigueur sont pour l'instant tout à
fait fonctionnels sur d'autres sujets
elle voulait une
commission plus géopolitique on a vu
effectivement l'Union Européenne à 27 à
la manœuvre sur l'Ukraine est-ce que
vous jugez ce bilan satisfaisant et
qu'est-ce que vous voudriez améliorer je
crois que l'Europe a été au rendez-vous
de l'Ukraine alors évidemment on peut
regretter telle et telle action ou
retard dans l'action mais en tout cas
l'Union européenne s'est montré unie et
solide et cela effectivement à la fois
je suis d'accord avec Madame vanderlione
et à la fois on peut aussi le mettre à
son crédit je crois que c'est important
de le souligner il faut continuer ce
soutien au peuple craignant qui ne passe
pas que par de la livraison d'armes mais
qui est aussi un soutien économique un
soutien dans l'accueil des ukrainiennes
et des Ukrainiens on doit tout faire
pour que l'élargissement à l'Ukraine
parce que on sait que à la prochaine
mandature le nombre des députés va
augmenter déjà de 704 à 720 en tout cas
et on voudrait augmenter le club
européen donc de 27 peut-être au pays
comme l'Ukraine et la Moldavie qui sont
effectivement un challenge géopolitique
par rapport par rapport à la Russie mais
aussi au balcon occidentaux ça
l'élargissement vous vous trouvez que
cette une bonne piste en tout cas on
doit tout faire pour que la guerre menée
par Vladimir Poutine à l'Ukraine
s'arrête et pour que le peuple ukrainien
retrouve sa souveraineté aujourd'hui le
peuple ukrainien nous dit sa volonté
d'appartenir à l'Union européenne
l'Union européenne vous savez pour moi
ce n'est pas une réalité historique
intangible qui est faite par une espèce
d'essence mais c'est un projet politique
le projet politique d'une Europe qui
soit terre des droits et liberté qui
respecte l'État de droit la séparation
des pouvoirs les droits et libertés
fondamentaux et fondamentales des
citoyennes et des citoyens et bien si
l'Union européenne chez l'Ukraine
souhaite rentrer dans ce projet
politique alors il faut y aller le bémol
que je mets parce que nous avons entendu
on sous la vente d'arleyen nous dire on
va faire élargissement et
approfondissement mais on a un besoin
réel de changer les règles de
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne
aujourd'hui elles sont bloquées parce
qu'un certain nombre de décisions sont
prises à l'unanimité notamment en
matière fiscale ce qui conditionne
notamment la capacité de l'Union à agir
par exemple à travers des plans
d'investissement mais aussi en menant
des politiques sociales donc on a besoin
que ces règles-là changent il faut
peut-être imaginer
des manières de s'associer qui puissent
être différentes en tout cas cette
sortie de l'unanimité elle avait été
promise il y a quelques années par
Ursula vanderlione nous n'en entendons
plus parler aujourd'hui et il faut
effectivement que si on aille dans cette
direction élargissement et
approfondissement et de pairs oui elle
est bloquée aussi par les mauvais élèves
de l'Union européenne qui a envie de
continuer à mettre leurs véto sur
beaucoup de choses on pense à la Hongrie
par exemple et à la Pologne donc tant
antimilitariste est-ce que les vers face
à la guerre en Ukraine sont en train de
revoir leur vision de la défense et en
particulier d'une défense européenne et
d'une ou de l'investissement dans ce
domaine je ne crois pas parce que nous
avons toujours souhaité doté l'Union
européenne d'une défense effectivement
intégrée c'est à dire une défense qui se
décide au niveau de voilà d'une décision
entre les Etats mais qui soit trans
européenne sous supervision et dans la
transparence par le Parlement européen
cela nous l'avons toujours promu on a
besoin aujourd'hui d'aider un peuple qui
est agressé et donc c'est normal de lui
fournir de lui procurer un soutien
militaire qui est un soutien militaire
qui se passe aussi par la livraison
d'armes une Europe de la défense à notre
sens elle doit aussi avoir pour objet la
construction de la paix à travers le
monde et donc aussi la lutte contre le
désarmement alors Marie tout ça à peine
désigné tête de liste pour les verres
pour les prochaines élections
européennes vous avez été huées à
l'université de la France insoumise à
Valence parce que en quelque sorte vous
empiez de bâtir une liste commune de la
nupesse pour aller aux élections
européennes le dialogue et l'Alliance
sont impossibles non le dialogue est
possible c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
j'ai été d'ailleurs invité aux
universités d'été de la France insoumise
ça a été effectivement compliqué je vais
pas vous le cacher je crois que on a
l'existence d'une coalition politique en
France qui ne trouve pas d'écho au
niveau européen pourquoi et bien tout
simplement parce que le scrutin européen
est inscritant à la proportionnelle à un
tour qui permet à toute la palette des
nuances de la gauche et de son lien à
l'Europe de s'exprimer un travail de
convergence a eu lieu c'est vrai entre
les différents partis de la gauche
française partenaires de la nupesse ce
travail n'a pas abouti n'est pas
suffisant pour que nous puissions nous
dire que nous allions ensemble aux
élections européennes alors que cette
diversité de palettes puisse s'expliquer
nous sommes en particulier les plus pro
européen les plus fédéralistes nous
avons envie de cette défense intégrée de
ces modes de modalités de décision
européens sur les bâtiments publics non
mais vous savez je suis pas sûr que ça
embête tant que ça la France insoumise
je crois que aujourd'hui c'est normal et
quelque part c'est une force de
l'habitude que nous présentions chacun
des listes autonome en tout cas c'est la
volonté de ma formation qui a voté à 86
% pour cela moi ce que je dis est-ce que
je répète aux militantes aux militants
de la France insoumise c'est nous sommes
ensemble pour mener des combats que nous
devons mener sur le terrain en France au
Parlement européen mais les sons aux
électeurs aux électrices au peuple
souverain le choix de décider de
l'atteinte de la coloration qu'il
souhaite donner aux listes dans le cadre
des élections européennes vos propres
universités d'été ont été marqués par
une polémique sur la venue du rappeur
Médine à qui on attribué des propos
antisémites est-ce qu'il y a une
ambiguïté sur des questions sociétés
aussi importantes chez les Verts une
ambiguïté non je ne crois pas écoutez
vous savez j'ai dit que j'avais à dire
sur cette invitation et le sujet de
linguistique contre vous étiez compte et
le sujet de l'antisémitisme c'est un
sujet qui est absolument crucial et
d'ailleurs on l'a vu dans l'actualité
européenne ces dernières semaines on a
par exemple en Bavière des questions
très importantes qui ont été posées sur
l'antisémitisme nous ne devons jamais
oublier que l'antisémitisme est un fléau
qu'il nous faut combattre coûte que
coûte voilà merci à vous Marie Toussain
d'avoir essayé notre invité aujourd'hui
merci de nous avoir suivis sur France 24
et sur Public Sénat vous restez en notre
compagnie pour maintenant revenir sur ce
débat sur l'état de l'Union avec deux
autres groupes politiques qui vont le
commenter à comparer leur petite note
c'est tout de suite c'est le débat
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre au Parlement de
Strasbourg où se tenait mercredi 13
septembre le grand oral de rentrée de la
présidente de la Commission européenne à
quelques mètres d'ici à la déroulé son
discours sur l'état de l'Union le
dernier de son mandat très politique et
la défendu son bilan et tracer les
priorités avant les élections
européennes de juin 2024 elle a donné
des gages à la droite avec des tonalités
très probusiness mettons l'accent sur la
croissance la compétitivité l'industrie
les entreprises les agriculteurs oui
alors si elle continue à soutenir le
pacte vert projet phare de la transition
écologique de sa mandature on sent bien
que certains aménagements se profilent
car la position de l'Allemande Ursula
wanderlione est délicate il espère
rempiler pour cinq ans à la tête de
l'exécutif elle doit envoyer des signaux
à son parti le Parti populaire européen
et à une dizaine de chefs d'États qui
réclament une pause réglementaire en
environnementale avec d'ailleurs la
guerre en Ukraine mais aussi la montée
en puissance de la Chine elle aura fait
de son exécutive la commission
géopolitique qu'elle souhaitait présente
en tout cas sur tous les fronts alors
pour analyser un les grandes lignes de
ce discours 2 euros députés une
Allemande Nicolas Bert bonjour du groupe
rognoux EUROPE plutôt au centre de
l'hémicycle et puis une Française
socialiste Sylvie Guillaume bonjour à
toutes les deux je voudrais d'abord vous
demander comment vous avez trouvé ce
discours Nicolas Bert
convaincu je trouvais j'étais déçue sur
le contenu c'est la structure aussi sur
la température je trouvais que c'était
plutôt tiède pour moi c'était pas une
réponse sur l'écran des filles que les
citoyens ont surtout la compétitivité et
tout ce qui est job bureau
en plus la migration
l'innovation alors tout ce que fait que
on peut guider comme Europe vraiment
dans le monde alors je sais pas c'était
pour moi plutôt une tentative adaptée à
de correction de bilan de dernière
minute plutôt déçu Sylvie Guillaume et
vous oui moi j'ai trouvé que bon il y a
des choses sur lesquelles on pouvait
être d'accord comme par exemple l'idée
de l'élargissement l'idée de faire par
exemple de du numérique et de Lia un
contrôle quelque chose qui soit vraiment
un pas mal pour l'Union européenne mais
globalement j'ai trouvé ce discours très
très désincarné on savait pas très très
bien à qui s'adressait ce discours mais
en tout cas pas aux citoyen j'ai trouvé
donc voilà une forme de désincarnation
par rapport aux enjeux réels des gens
beaucoup de choses effectivement je suis
d'accord avec Nicolas Bert sur très très
probusiness c'est à dire qu'on sentait
qu'il y a vraiment une dimension on
s'adresse aux entreprises alors
apprendre à dire pas tout à fait les
mêmes conclusions mais peu de choses par
exemple moi je trouve qu'il y a
énormément manqué c'est des éléments sur
la lutte contre la pauvreté justement on
est dans une phase tout à fait
particulière avec de l'inflation
et effectivement rien sur ça donc je
trouve que la lutte contre la précarité
était vraiment le gros absent de ce de
ce disque la moitié de son discours tout
de même porté sur le pacte vert sur la
transition écologique nécessaire on le
sent bien mais avec des tonalités très
libérales vous le disiez un fort message
à destination des PME de des industriels
la transition ne se fera pas aux dépens
de la compétitivité c'est ce qu'elle a
expliqué exactement c'est vraiment le
message central donc c'est une option
après moi elle a sa légitimité elle dit
mais on peut effectivement contester
cela parce que en fait il manque un
registre supplémentaire c'est que le
pacte vert pour lutter contre le
changement climatique c'est faut pas
avoir le pied sur le frein maintenant il
faut pas se contenter des mesures
existantes il faut avancer il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin c'est un changement
de modèle qu'il faut maintenant mettre
dans les tuyaux et ça on ne l'a pas du
tout senti dans son dans son message et
dans son discours alors sur le
concurrent chinois elle a été assez
claire et assez agressive notamment sur
les véhicules électriques on l'écoute
secteur
des véhicules électriques
c'est une industrie essentielle pour
l'économie propre avec un énorme
potentiel pour l'Europe mais les marchés
mondiaux sont aujourd'hui inondés de
voitures électriques chinoises bon
marché
dans le prix est maintenu
artificiellement bas par la subventions
publiques massive cela fausse notre
marché je vous annonce donc aujourd'hui
que la Commission ouvre une enquête anti
subventions sur les véhicules
électriques en provenance de Chine
Nicolas Bert c'est une des grandes
annonces de ce discours cette enquête
est-ce que ça va nous permettre de
rattraper notre retard face au géant
chinois
oui mais c'est aussi par ça fait partie
du problème parce que elle annonce elle
annonce elle annonce moi je l'avais
l'impression mais qu'est-ce qu'elle a
fait pendant 4 ans c'est elle qui guide
qui préside la commission depuis plus de
4 ans alors pour moi la mise en oeuvre
ça c'est qu'il faut prouver aux citoyens
et c'est pas encore fait alors oui en
tout ce qui était un prévu la pandémie
la guerre de la Russie en Ukraine là
elle a plutôt bien fait mais plutôt
si on parle de la compétitivité la vie
annoncée depuis 4 ans une initiative de
réduire la bureaucratie surtout pour les
PME rien c'est fait hier elle a annoncé
quelque chose mais qui ne qui ne se fait
pas en oeuvre vous dites pratiques en
détail en concrète parce que moi je
crois qu'il faut réduire la bureaucratie
pas seulement 25% mais 50%
des entrepreneurs ils peuvent créer des
bulots qui peuvent créer l'innovation
qu'ils peuvent vraiment travailler pour
les citoyens oui mais alors justement
précisément il y a les industriels qui
sont beaucoup cités même si les mesures
concrètes sont pas toujours au
rendez-vous les agriculteurs maintes
fois citées aussi c'est assez nouveau
avec une priorité pour la souveraineté
alimentaire européenne qui va se faire
vous le penser vous dans les prochaines
législatures au détriment de la
biodiversité et de la cause animale on
pense aux poussins broyés aux loup
évidemment à la biodiversité le point
que vous soulevez très très important et
c'est d'ailleurs un des sujets sur
lesquels on peut rebondir je crois qu'on
a une vraie problématique sur
l'alimentation y compris parce qu'il y a
quelquefois des compétitions qui se font
sur les prix des compétitions qui sont
totalement anormales sur des de
l'alimentation vivrière on va dire donc
il y a un vrai sujet là-dessus mais
d'une certaine manière la manière dont
c'est présenté c'est effectivement le
choix qu'on va devoir faire on ne peut
pas céder la le confort de vie des gens
leur emploi leur niveau de vie
pour la question de la lutte contre le
changement climatique nous devons mener
les deux en maintenant et c'est
parfaitement possible ça c'est le choix
que devra faire se l'avant-dernière
est-ce qu'elle cédrat à son parti
d'origine le PPE ou pas on a entendu des
effectivement des options au sein du PPE
qui était ces derniers temps extrêmement
sereinte parce qu'en effet on
s'adressant comme ça aussi maintes fois
aux agriculteurs Nicolas Bert c'est
aussi une façon de draguer un électorat
plutôt à qui au PPE sont partis et
mécontents dernièrement en fait on est
en campagne là tout le monde
oui bien sûr mais surtout les
agriculteurs eux aussi sont
entrepreneurs alors ils savent très bien
comment faire leur bulots alors produire
de la nourriture mais il ils ont
vraiment ce poids de trop de règles donc
là on est d'accord
vous êtes plutôt d'accord du coup avec
Ursula vanderlain qui qui dit attention
voilà votre elle lui donne les poids se
les épaules et après elle dit ouais mais
je vais je vais vous aider on voit pas
des vraiment concrètes actions on voit
des des mots elle annonce mais on voit
pas qu'elle fait quelque chose que met
quelque chose en oeuvre
la présidente de la commission de la
future candidate du PPE à l'élection de
juin prochain c'est effectivement il
fallait essayer de distinguer quel était
le qui parlait en fait la future
candidate ou la présidente actuelle il
faut pas confondre l'avenir dehors se
laver lion avec l'avenir de l'Union
européenne mais sur cette question de
l'emploi moi j'entends ce que dit
Nicolas faire sur il faut pouvoir
recruter il faut moins de bureaucratie
mais la question du nombre d'emplois
disponibles par exemple dans l'Union
européenne à une se pose un peu
différemment maintenant il y a de
l'emploi dans l'Union qui a été abordé
également c'est aussi des emplois de
qualité il y a la question des salaires
qui se posent et sur ça je pense qu'il y
a de la régulation à faire il y a des
impulsions à donner et ces impulsions là
elles n'ont pas été données aujourd'hui
il y a eu un moment d'émotion dans
l'hémicycle c'est quand Ursula
vanderleyen a rendu hommage aux victimes
craéniennes de la guerre à travers
l'histoire notamment de Victoria Mélina
une écrivaine morte sous les bombes
brusques un soutien à notre voisin
ukrainien réaffirmé mercredi on l'écoute
mesdames et messieurs nous serons aux
côtés de l'Ukraine tout au long du
chemin aussi longtemps que nécessaire
depuis le début de la guerre 4 millions
d'ukrainien ont trouvé refuge dans notre
union et je tiens à leur dire que
ils sont aujourd'hui toujours les
bienvenus tout comme pendant les
terribles première semaine de la guerre
nous avons fait en sorte qu'ils aient un
accès à un logement à des soins de santé
au marché du travail et bien plus encore
mesdames et messieurs les députés c'est
ainsi que l'Europe a répondu à l'appel
de l'histoire je suis dès lors fier
d'annoncer que la Commission proposera
d'étendre notre protection temporaire
aux Ukrainiens dans l'Union européenne
notre soutien à l'Ukraine perdurera
alors Nicolas Bert on a bien compris
qu'on accueillait très bien au moins les
réfugiés Ukrainiens ça c'était ce qu'on
faisait bien pour l'Ukraine quoi d'autre
ouais mais on était vraiment en commun
pour agir très très rapidement sur la
Russie les sanctions alors 11 paquets de
sanctions on est vraiment ensemble on a
ensemble dans la durée c'est ça là c'est
ça dans la durée je crois en vous pouvez
maintenant sur le chemin d'ici des
beaucoup plus vite surtout ce qui est le
soutien militaire parce que là il manque
du matériel de la munition on a agi ici
avec la régulation mais pourquoi il faut
vraiment livrer beaucoup plus vite pour
les Ukrainiens parce que ça va durer
encore mais on a aussi dans les mains
comme bien de temps alors voilà
justement parce que sur le terrain
militaire et de la défense on aide
suffisamment pour que l'Ukraine ne perde
pas la guerre mais pas suffisamment pour
qu'elle la gagne il faut aller plus loin
oui absolument la question de la
fourniture de matériel supplémentaire se
pose et elle se pose depuis longtemps
c'est d'ailleurs assez curieux de ne
rien entendre de la part de quelqu'un
dont on dit qu'elle pourrait également
être candidate pour diriger l'autane
donc la question effectivement
l'Atlantique
je crois que plus largement la question
de la défense a été assez peu aussi
abordé
manifestement si ce concours de
circonstance particulier de la guerre en
Ukraine pose la question de la
fourniture d'armes comme on vient de le
faire maintenant elle pose aussi la
question de la défense européenne
objectivement la puissance l'Europe
puissance d'un certain point de vue
elle se la VAN derlione elle est arrivée
sur la promesse de rendre la commission
géopolitique est-ce que pour vous elle a
la tenue cette promesse là on a fait un
acteur incontournable et qui a une
vision géopolitique claire renouvelée
peut-être par les derniers événements
je crois qu'on trouve maintenant de
plusieurs pas mais vraiment à la
dernière minute alors par exemple
comment on peut agir maintenant avec les
matières premières alors qu'on veut
vraiment d'avoir des partenariats avec
des autres pays pour la production pour
tout ce qui est et ce qui nous fait
moins dépendant de la Chine quand essaye
vraiment d'avoir un club pas seulement
dans libre et échange mais aussi ce qui
est par exemple les matières premières
mais elle a perdu tellement de temps
parce que elle n'a pas vraiment
elle n'est pas arrivée à vraiment
prendre tous les pays membres en
ensemble il y avait de très différentes
bois dans le monde et ça c'est contre
nous Nicolas Bert depuis le début vous
avez l'air complètement désabusé face à
à la présidente de la Commission
européenne peut-être
moi je suis pas en campagne parce que je
vais pas faire la campagne l'année
prochaine je fais pas me représenter
mais je suis votre famille que quelqu'un
qui a tellement beaucoup d'instruments
et de possibilités n'a pas vraiment
livré pour les citoyens ce qu'il faut et
moi j'ai vraiment la peur que ça tombe
sur les mains des populistes aux deux
côtés à droite et à gauche et quand à la
fin on a peut-être des situations comme
en France en Italie ou c'est presque ou
même plus de la majorité c'est vrai que
Manfred Weber le patron du PPE il a un
peu tenté de parler à l'extrême droite
voire de dialoguer avec l'extrême droite
en vue des élections européennes c'est
moi le cas de d'Ursula vandaleyen
peut-être quand même oui j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a un petit débat
interne au sein du PPS sur sur ce sujet
en tout cas vous dites que demande ça
devrait bien on a des signes il a donné
un peu plus que des signes puisque des
votes conjoints ont eu lieu sur un
certain nombre de sujets il y a pas
d'ambiguïté sur le sens de la main
tendue de enfred Weber je crois qu'on
arrive à la fin de l'émission je veux
dire deux choses en termes de sujets
elle aurait pu évoquer quelque chose de
très important de mon point de vue
j'espère que ça fera partie de la
prochaine commission prochain mandat la
question du logement par exemple qui est
absolument fondamental dans l'Union
européenne on le sait c'est une
composante de la vie des citoyens qui
doit être mieux alimenter en termes de
fond et en termes de développement puis
peut-être pour conclure sur sur une
phrase ou un peu ironique il y a eu un
côté concours de circonstance dans cette
danse mandat ou plein d'événements sont
arrivés madame vanderlione a été reçu
première à son concours de circonstances
il faut passer au-delà dans la prochaine
mandat Nicolas Bert ensemble déjà à
l'heure du bilan qu'est-ce qui a manqué
alors au-delà de la concurrence la
compétitivité si lui Guillaume parlait
notamment du logement pour vous c'est
quoi oui mais pour moi c'est vraiment
qu'on livre à ce que les citoyens
attendent dans les temps de guerre avec
une inflation alors que en aide vraiment
les entreprises
stupide en fait c'est toujours
l'économie qui prime à base de notre
prospérité c'est aussi la base pour être
capable d'intrrer dans la migration ce
qu'on reçoit parce que ils sont des
vrais réfugiés et là aussi le pacte de
migration ça ça manque de mettre en
manœuvre et comme ça moi je trouve elle
a perdu trop de temps moi j'ai vraiment
cru que ça va être une interne de
réforme moi je sois pas de réforme et
surtout les 50 décisions sur les
compétition
Ursula 50 plus ah je sais pas si elle va
se présenter
parce que la dernière fois elle a pris
un détour pour avoir ce cette position
là peut-être elle va être dans la
compétition de tous les parties merci à
vous en tout cas d'avoir très bien
illustré ce débat et finalement la vraie
rentrée européenne de l'union avec le
discours sur l'ital de l'Union très
remarqué et suivi et vous restez sur nos
antennes pour la suite des programmes à
très bientôt
[Musique]